what up space fam golson here from anime
up pro and i'm here today to discuss the
latest episode of the final attack on
titan season
if you like the idea of me dropping
weekly episode reviews and want to keep
them coming then the best thing to do is
warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and
while you wait for the next insane
episode to drop feel free to check out
our growing attack on titan playlist
where we got videos about all the titan
shifters and their powers all the
acronyms and their powers the titans
ranked from weakest to strongest and
much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all
this episode starts with a flashback of
reiner and his mom talking
and his mom lets him know that his
father isn't here because he's marlene
but
makes him think that if they were to
become honorary marlenes which you can
do by becoming a warrior and inheritor
of a titan power
then things would be different remember
marlenes usually view aldians like
reiner and his mom as
devils who can turn into man-eating
titans the anime is definitely breezing
through the chapters
as a lot of things are cut short or cut
out when compared to the manga and we'll
get
into some of those things as i move
forward with the review
but this will be a mainly reiner focused
episode
helping us to understand his evolution
from weak boy wanting to make his mom
happy and reunite his family to where he
is now a clearly
traumatized man we get to see reiner and
other ld and children pushing themselves
for a chance to become titan shifters
and thus honorary marlins the anime
takes out a lot of reiner's struggle
like his falling behind marcel in the
run better told beating him at the
firing range annie beating him in combat
and then in the manga it shows him
finally doing well in a written test
because he is able to illustrate so much
loyalty to marley
and because of this final reason he got
chosen as a warrior candidate
and pretty much that just means he got
chosen because he is sufficiently
brainwashed into thinking that people on
the island are actually devils
the anime skips the scene of him telling
his mom the good news that he became a
warrior candidate
and it skips him promising to inherit
one of the nine titans to her so they
can become honorary marlians
during the convo between zeke and the
other candidates in the manga they're in
the middle of physical training while
they are just chilling out eating apples
in the anime
six out of the seven will inherit powers
and we get the scene where reiner is
optimistic but porco says he'll never
inherit it since he's the weakest of the
group in addition to saying
all reiner's got his loyalty he also
mentions that reiner makes sure to lick
the captain's boots every day
something that didn't make it into the
anime reiner's response
is also shortened in the manga he uses
more extreme brainwashed rhetoric saying
and i quote don't you know who's on that
island devils who've brought fear to the
entire world
it's only a matter of time till they
start slaughtering again unless we kill
them are you insulting our mission
end quote while in the anime this is
shortened too are you making fun of our
mission
i would have personally liked for them
to keep this in my opinion important
info
and maybe even add a bit more but it
definitely seems like the anime is
rushing through the manga here
in the anime reiner also calls him a
stray restorationist rather than an
aldean restorationist who supports king
fritz again
less specific porko knocks reiner to the
ground and bertolt helps him in the
meantime annie seems to kill a
grasshopper and i'd love to know what
you guys think of that
why did both the manga and anime
emphasize that there is definitely a
parallel there
with the way that the marleyans viewed
the aldians as disposable and sub-human
as if they were insects as well when
talking to bertolt
reiner reveals that he doesn't care
about emir's curse
which means that titan inheritors can
only live for 13 years after inheriting
the titan powers
clearly that time limit is on bertolt's
mind but for reiner he is willing to
dramatically shorten his life
if it will make his parents proud and if
his father will finally accept him
and there'll be one big happy family
which would make his mom
really happy even though reiner is the
guy who helped destroy the walls and
kill
countless innocent people in season 1
including aaron's mom
we see here that he's not necessarily a
villain in black and white terms
in his view and the view of his friends
and family and his nation
he's a hero who's trying to save the
aldians on the continent
and make his mom happy not to mention he
was brainwashed as a child
he's obviously still wrong for what he
did but we're starting to see that
things are never
that black and white in attack on titan
let me know how you feel about reiner
after this episode by the way in the
comments do you simply hate him or do
you have some pity for him as well
we also see aaron during this time whose
upbringing is very different than rhinos
up to this point
they both have walls that surround them
but reiner has been discriminated
against and is willingly putting himself
through hellish trials
in order to make his mom happy while kit
aaron up to this point at least is more
carefree even bored he wishes something
would happen
something out of the ordinary little
does he know that he'll get his wish
but in the most horrifying way when the
titans finally break through the wall
we then get an intro to all of the titan
powers inherited by the marlene warriors
which is cool
we actually get some images added here
which we don't have in the manga
they let us know that the female titan
is versatile has great mobility
endurance and its hardened strikes are
very destructive
especially when you combine them with
annie's martial arts skills
the female titan can also call pure
titans then there's the armor titan
specializing in hardening
able to destroy the gates of any wall
with a full speed charge
it represents marley's shield and they
picked reiner because
of his perseverance the jaw titan is an
assault weapon
it's fast and small with both jaws and
claws that can crush nearly anything
and i'd like to know what it wouldn't be
able to crush personally if there is any
known thing that even
these claws and jaws couldn't destroy we
see that marcel's version like porco's
version has the hardening around the
face and claws
unlike amir's version they gave it to
marcel because he's quick-witted
and zeke's beast titan is brought up
along with its throwing ability and it's
mentioned that his blood has hidden
power
of course we know that this is referring
to zeke's unique abilities to control
titans that are turned using his
spinal fluid the car titan is known for
its outstanding endurance which makes it
suitable for long missions
and it's the only one outfitted with
different equipment to extend its
usefulness
pique got it thanks to her superior
judgment and finally there's a colossal
titan and they do a great job in the
anime of showing off its explosion
ability
it's straight up called the god of
destruction and i sort of feel bad for
bertolt because
they just say he'll be able to handle it
not mentioning any reasons or strengths
of his
as they did with pretty much everyone
else while these powers are reintroduced
to us
these guys are actually crushing a
nation at the same time
mag if the sane one still thinks it is
stupid to send children alone on a
mission to paradise island and he's
totally right they would go on to lose
three of the powers before luckily
getting the jaw titan back from emir
but the kids get sent anyways because
they are thought of as
aldian monsters rather than us human
children we again
see porco picking on reiner this time
because he's jealous that reiner got the
armored titan power instead of him
again marcel apologizes to reiner on his
brother's behalf
something he did the first time porco
quarreled with reiner too
finally we get the four kids reiner
bertolt annie and marcel
taking off and they are greeted by
crowds of people celebrating them as
heroes
including reiner's mom who is teary-eyed
and proud of her son
reiner waves to her but then notices a
figure entering a building
as it turns out this is his marlene
father and this is one of the saddest
moments for reiner we'll get into
another sad moment
later but here his dream of reuniting
his family is completely
dashed he did everything right he became
an honorary marleian
but we find out that doesn't actually
have any real meaning to marlene's
no matter how hard he tries reiner
cannot bridge the gap between himself
and a marleian in this society his
father even says that if anyone finds
out he's the dad
his whole family will be screwed and
he'll be hanged meaning a
honorary status is pretty much worthless
and b
he has another family that he cares way
more about and doesn't care about reiner
imagine doing all that work in the
pursuit of a dream and then having your
dad react like that
what reiner is being told here and at a
very young age is that no matter how
hard he works
he'll never be enough or as good as a
marlene he then jumps back to his mom
waving to him and he decides even
without a dad
he's still a chosen warrior he'll still
save everyone and be the world's hero
some pretty important stuff is cut out
of the manga here including the fact
that his dad
calls him and his mom devils and the
fact that before he leaves his mom tells
him that she's sure
his father is praying for reiner's
success she has no idea that reiner went
to see his dad
and his hopes got completely trampled on
and so the manga is even sadder for
these reasons
but anyways we jump to the island and
the brainwashed and naive
reiner keeps on getting more and more
disillusioned he realizes that he's the
only one present who truly views the
islanders
as pure devils and so felt no remorse at
the thought of destroying them
mercilessly
for him he is like a chosen angel of god
who's charged with fighting pure evil
devils while the others know that
they're going to be killing humans
and the only difference between these
humans is what side of the wall they
happen to be on
then marcel drops the truth bomb and he
says sorry again to reiner suggesting
that he was probably apologizing to
reiner about this the whole time
reiner was never meant to be chosen as a
warrior he was the weakest
however marcel talked down about his
brother and elevated reiner to the
military
so that he could save porco his little
brother from the tragic fate
of becoming a titan shifter and getting
only 13 years longer to live
and even that is only if he didn't die
on a dangerous mission first
this continues to mess with reiner
because his brainwashed self
never thought that being chosen as a
warrior could be a bad thing
so he thinks it's absurd that marcel is
apologizing for making reiner's dreams
come true
reiner's naive ideology was challenged
when he found
out that his father would never accept
him and his mom and now again
when the value of becoming a warrior has
been brought into doubt
in a short period of time everything he
thought he knew
his whole world view and purpose for
living has been brought into serious
doubt
combine all that with being a double
agent child soldier
later on and you can totally see how he
developed mental issues
like split personality disorder but as
if him hearing this truth bomb from
marcel
after everything wasn't traumatizing
enough this is when amir's mindless
titan appears and almost eats reiner
he then witnesses marcel save him and
die before his eyes and then reiner just
runs away
definitely not the behavior you'd expect
from a self-proclaimed hero
at this point reiner is the epitome of
cowardice which you can't really blame
that much because he's a little kid
he's crying thinking that annie and
bertolt got killed
too and that he'll be next when annie
kicks him he screams like a baby
scared out of his mind and it's funny
how annie mentions that reiner for the
first time
beat her in a long distance race which
further emphasizes how scared he was
annie points out that they should have
transformed and stole the jaw titan back
immediately
but when reiner and bethod started
running away so did she
without marcel they have no leader and
that could lead to many more
mistakes and problems as a result annie
wants to go back to marley but
reiner won't have it notably in the
manga he gets a flashback of his mom
saying
she knows he'll be able to complete the
mission and that is why he refuses to go
back now
he doesn't want to disappoint her more
than anything in the anime
annie just suggests that reiner won't go
back because he'll get killed for
messing up
he goes on to rationally explain that
they'll all be in trouble
since they all ran away and catching the
draw won't
be possible because it is the fastest
and can run away and they'll be sitting
ducks after using too much power
annie starts to accept that reiner is
right about them needing to get the
founding titan
but she's also angry and blames him for
the situation
she proceeds to beat him up badly in the
manga it seemed to pass quicker since it
only lasted
a page and a half but in the anime it
affected me more because of how long it
seemed to go on for
reiner then proceeds to tackle annie
holds her in a chokehold and says that
reiner is dead he'll become marcel the
confident leader they need
and that is the moment that reiner
changed from the worst student and
crybaby to the outwardly confident
reiner we see
during the beginning of attack on titan
the one aaron looks up to
obviously reiner is messed up and does
horrible things but i do like this idea
of being able to transform yourself
in order to achieve your goal it's
unfortunate though that reiner's goal
includes making the lives of the aldians
within the walls a living hell
we then come full circle to the
beginning of attack on titan when the
colossal titan appears
except this time we focus on the warrior
perspective in the manga
it did include annie's titan being used
to attract
pure titans so that there would be
maximum destruction after the gate was
destroyed
in the anime they missed this so that
you could potentially assume that annie
didn't have as important a role to play
in the destruction
we also see the smiling titan pass right
by bertolt very abnormal behavior so
this suggests that dina fritz's titan
did appear to be drawn to her husband
grisha yeager and his new family
after all after passing by bertholdt it
can't be a coincidence that she goes for
and kills her old husband's new wife
then reiner transforms
and says he's not ready for this to end
because he still doesn't understand
anything and as
he thinks that he breaks through the
second gate in his armor titan form
notably in the manga the translation is
i don't want this to end here i haven't
changed
anything yet a significantly different
translation so the anime focuses on more
knowledge
while in the manga the focus is on
making an impact on the world before he
goes but either way it's a powerful
moment coming from someone who wasn't
supposed to be born
since marleans aren't supposed to have
kids with aldians he wasn't supposed to
be a warrior and
he was supposed to have died instead of
marcel yet despite all those things he's
still here and refuses to go down
without a fight
without trying to move forward and get
some answers for his seemingly
unwanted existence by the time annie
awakens within wall rose
reiner is the clear leader of the group
comforting them
and saying he'll be the warrior he
should have been keep in mind that
reiner's like a 12 year old child right
now
and he's taking all of this
responsibility on his shoulders although
we know his actions are wrong
we can also see from this episode how he
got to the messed up place he got to
and he clearly wasn't motivated by evil
we also have some fill in the blank
moments in this episode
like how they got their backstory from a
guy who left his children behind when
the titans arrived
and then later hanged himself and we see
annie trail kenny ackerman
trying to find out about the royal
family only to run away from him when
she figures out how skilled he is i
gotta say annie's kick that helps her
get away
is beautifully animated here and despite
some people not loving the cgi
this season i think the animation has
been great so far
if it continues to keep up this level of
animation until the end
i'll be more than satisfied then we get
annie saying to reiner and bertott that
she wants to leave to go back to marley
bring the info they have while reiner
refuses since they have very little
information
considering they've been here for five
years reiner suggests destroying wall
rose
and when annie mentions his new friends
dying reiner says that they are not
friends but devils and despite what
reiner says
it's clear that the lying takes a toll
on him as we'll see later in the episode
when he almost takes his own life annie
is distant and aloof with the others not
wanting to be friends with her enemies
while reiner is even more committed to
killing them but acts like they're best
friends
it's almost scary how good reiner is at
deception though
it does come back to haunt him later on
we see aaron getting tired from training
and reiner showing up like a big brother
to motivate him he asks how he can be
like
reiner and he's worried about dying
without doing a damn thing keep in mind
that's what reiner feared when he broke
through the gate in the manga
dying without doing or changing anything
so the parallel between them
is even more clear in the manga reiner
sees his younger self in
aaron and tells him to do what he has to
do
and to keep moving forward he says
that's all we can do
and finishes off the speech by saying
that he knows aaron can do it and that
behavior
juxtapose with the fact that he's the
enemy who killed aaron's mom and so many
others
is too much for reiner to take it haunts
him to the present day
the lie he lived and we see him in the
present with a rifle in his mouth
the only thing that keeps him from
taking his own life is the fact that
falco happens to hit the wall
and disjogs reiner out of his mental
health and reminds him that he still has
a purpose
to look after the younger generation of
warrior candidates if it wasn't for them
reiner would have already taken his own
life because of all the horrible things
he's done
this episode ends with falco seeing a
self-proclaimed
liar who says he's being treated for
emotional trauma and honestly i feel
like almost everyone in this series
should be treated for emotional trauma
this whole conversation is fascinating
falco is sad because gabby will inherit
the titan power but the wounded
aldian soldier is glad falco won't
inherit the power
because he seems like a good guy and he
wants falco to live a long life but
falco doesn't want gabby to get the
power in his place
because he wants her to live a long and
happy life so he hates the fact that
he's so powerless to do anything about
it
the wounded soldier muses about war and
how if everyone knew what would come of
it nobody would go to war
and i'll quote him here because it's
important stuff he continues and i quote
most people are pushed by something
forced to march into hell
that something wasn't their choice their
situation or others made them do it
but people who push their own backs see
a different kind of hell they can
see something beyond the hell it might
be hope it might be another hell
only those who keep moving forward will
ever know end quote
and bam we see a future aaron looking
back at us
and if you didn't recognize that from
his look and from his overall importance
in the scene
then you'll remember that reiner had
told him the exact same thing in the
flashback about moving forward what a
crazy episode and really served as a
tribute to reiner's character
and his evolution from the beginning to
now how he went from a young optimistic
boy to a suicidal depressed adult
after experiencing the realities of war
first hand and just as reiner decided to
keep moving forward all those years ago
when he broke through the second gate
aaron clearly has a plan to keep moving
forward
putting himself through hell out of his
own free will hoping for something good
but knowing that it may just be another
hell but still he doesn't want to die
without doing anything
i gotta say this is arguably my favorite
manga ever
and the way it captures the complexities
of reality is something very few stories
can do so well
i think this final anime season is going
to be great just as the first three
episodes have been
even though they do cut out more manga
stuff than i would have liked them to
cut out i'm not a huge fan of that
but what can you do either way i am
hyped about this final season i'm hyped
to see how this mind-blowing modern
classic will end
and i can't wait for the next episode
but anyways thanks for watching
if you do want to see episode reviews
like this one for future episodes then
let me know in the comments and by
warhammer
smashing that like button if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next insane episode to drop
feel free to check out my growing attack
on time playlist where we got videos
about the titan shifters and their
powers
the acronyms and their powers the titans
ranked for weakens the strongest and
much
much more link to that is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twigo himself and the most donated
champion of the world
alpha sigma and or the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans in grata the world acquire
respect liam thompson
pattay heffarutheon phoenix anime 987
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tinnell
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers
angel crews anatoly kazowski cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
font alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami
and water the red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games manwa freaks
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime
life and of course thank memes so check
out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel
by clicking the blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more
content that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support as you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you